ja wir wollen nicht nur mit den jüngsten
Bundestagsabgeordneten sprechen sondern
auch mit einem der ältesten schön dass
die Zeit für uns haben er es freut mich
ihr habt wahrscheinlich die ganze
Sommerpause gebraucht für diesen tollen
Gag oder es gibt natürlich auch viele
ältere Abgeordnete für die Twitter
komplett Neuland ist guten Abend ja
hallo ich glaube das ist nicht eine
Frage des Alters beim Thema Wohnungsnot
ist ein Lösungsansatz natürlich auch das
generationsübergreifende Wohnzimmer z.B
ein junger Student zusammen mit einem
Senioren ja gut okay also ich finde
Wohnungsnot ist ein Thema beim
heizungsgesetz wurde die Ausnahme Regel
für über 80-jährige jetzt doch wieder
gestrichen da machen sich viele
Betroffene natürlich Sorgen ja alles
fast wie immer im Alters wird zum Start
aber dafür der KÖSTER heute mal gut
angezogen also hat sie richtig Mühe
gegeben